hi there I'm an oppressor Robinson for
GameSpot here on the frontline at San
Diego comic-con 2014 I'm checking out
cosplay today and you know it's always
fun to cosplay by yourself but it's even
more fun to cosplay in a group we
checked out some of the best groups of
cosplayers here at comic-con 2014
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you do all bear a striking resemblance
to the people that you're cosplaying I
walked up and it's immediately clear oh
there they are
does it help to be cosplaying in a group
like this where people immediately
recognize who you are we get a tenth yes
it's yeah a lot of pictures but quite a
lot of attention yet there's a lot of
attention but also we get moved around
by security a lot because it tends to
form a crowd is that cool for you as
somebody who's wanting to represent a
character you really believe in to show
that off here yeah I really like it it's
fun and I think it's a good way to
promote you know feminism and you know
women in comics and movies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
cosplaying in a group is so much fun if
we cosplay together
what would we go as tweet at Anna
Prosser and let me know